first of these rules what do you think
of these rules you guys are already out
there doing work with drones and helping
companies do things what do you think of
these rules you know the rules obviously
are great news for everybody but the way
you got to think about it is this is
just the beginning of many iterations of
these rule and even more important is
remembering what's the swords was main
driver of all these changes you know a
year ago when you talk to the FAA
messaging from the fa was very different
from today it was what a year ago a year
ago you know the messages were a lot
more stricter than today and what's
changed the main driver is how many
companies big companies construction
mining getting involved in this new
market using the drones not only for R&D
purposes but not using it for operating
purposes now the rules actually any more
liberal than sort of the radio
controlled airplanes I may have to be
you have to be line of sight does that
give you room to do more than what you
could that's a helicopter that's correct
so I don't know if you're familiar with
the extension process the exception
we're one of the few companies were
granted extension 333 and that was in
there were some companies are doing work
in Hollywood as well absolutely under
the same extension but you had to you
have to have an actual commercial pilot
fly the drone but that was too steep for
a lot of these companies finding a
commercial pilots to too hard to find so
what they're doing today is basically
changing it so that you can basically go
to DMV almost and get your driver's
license the equivalent other drivers
license but isn't one of the things I
mean for example I won't name any kind
of your customers but i know that some
there's some big companies are building
corporate headquarters right right
flying around those corporate eyes isn't
the automation of that kind of thing we
can say i want an image i want you to go
around this building every day at noon
so i can look at the progress r and
programming that correct yes yeah it
shouldn't that be the great advantage of
business and don't these rules prohibit
that absolutely we believe that this is
again going back to what I said earlier
huge progress from a year ago a year
from now this is gonna be completely
different we believe that the FAA is
actually working closely with
these companies to allow for these
things to happen eventually our drugs
are fully autonomous so you basically
put a box it flies out it lands collects
a lot of data puts it on the cloud
without the need of human interaction
but we also have another product which
was called work mode which allows some
people to actually use our drone and
actually turn it into a work tool and
provide these services for construction
mining do you think regulation will be
more liberal in Europe and is this a
case of sort of the stem cell situation
repeat himself I heard that there's
deliveries been allowed off an island in
Germany right I mean absolutely I think
that it's it's going to be a race a lot
of these countries see the FA as the
main driver as the main guide for the
rules that including Europe but you've
seen you see a lot of progress in this
space and France Germany London where
you can actually be certified just like
you do at the DMV you know you take a
task simple test you get certification
you can actually operate commercially I
think the FA has seen a lot of that
progress outside of the US and they're
making changes towards that so some tech
companies having a hard time in Europe
other ones might might find it a lot
easier well yeah when you were growing
up such a small base is probably helpful
too I'm also concerned about you know
that it seems one of the great
businesses that could really benefit
from this is the examination of
pipelines something right it's required
by pipeline operators right now they
spend vast fortunes flying Cessnas with
special equipment to detect leaks and
pipelines and things right but these
rules seem like they would prohibit that
kind of use as well well you know you
have to make 55 pounds is actually
pretty heavy you could carry a really
good camera on that and you can actually
a pretty big enough battery to last very
long so you could actually make that
work with the new regulation now granted
the things are going to change this can
evolve is going to get easier and better
over time but with it with the size
regulations that we have today you can
actually operate and do a lot of the
stuff that you helicopters incessant is
due today do you think these rules are
gonna help you grow faster and are you
going fast already we already grown
faster already a lot of these companies
I already started using drones they move
away from the rd stage and actually
operating on drugs because they see the
value they get from this data so it's
just it's just gonna out meant our
growth yeah it is a big piece of lose
business is it gonna be
tiffany is it easier than Europe harder
you know the growth that we're seeing is
exponential it's incredible so last year
a lot of these companies were R&D mode
they're trying to test this thing this
things out the amount of companies are
jumping into the space is just gigantic
I mean the amount of requests and emails
were getting it's really hard to keep
focused that's why we believe that this
is gonna be a big industry not just for
us any of any drunk company who wants to
jump into space sounds like a blast
Christian sands of sky catch thank you
very much thank you for before we get
done here it's time for the be west
bight we focus on one number that tells
us a whole lot guest us Niccolo Demasi
has a bite I don't know what it is what
is it it's 400 million that's a lot of
something it's a lot of something it's
the number that I said on earnings call
we will exceed by the end of next year
in terms of total social followers
supporting blue celebrity games 400
million over 400 million we're at 240
million with Katy Perry and Kim
Kardashian look out for the next couple
earnings calls you'll see some new
exciting announcement and Katie adding
James Bond your needs that's a big I'm
not counting James Bond for that i'm
talking about direct celebrities that
will be working with over the next 18
months wow that's uh how can you safely
predict such a number well we have a
great track record a glue of sort of
beating all of the numbers we've given
right so we might we might have a few
more million in the bag that haven't
been announced yet real I mean it that
the phenomenon of gaming is just an
amazing thing Niccolo to ask am really
glad you're able to join us I should go
for today's shows a lot of fun told you
go by quick well I knew you had draft
and someone who was good-looking with
you know Emily on
so here I am if that